well holy smoke is this ain't no jokers
welcome into the
45th episode ever of millennial i mean
excuse me the ice
coffee hour with graham and jack they
have made
50 313
in the history of this channel congrats
gentlemen and thank you
for having me thank you so much that was
really good that was really good you
know mateo right now is right after that
calculating calculating all the numbers
i'm curious to see what it's going to be
this episode 50 grand
50 000 that's pretty amazing that's
incredible that's a full-on salary
yes that's crazy how long you guys about
a year right you've been doing this
a year in a couple months no it hasn't
been a year yet
no a year in a couple months oh okay
okay it sounded like a year and a half
okay and a couple months yeah and this
is my third time on the channel so
thanks for having me
you've been on the channel more times
than anyone else that's true
we've had a few people twice but never
for a third time
okay well i appreciate it guys thank you
you're just so good the first two times
we had to have you back we want to know
what stocks to buy
oh man what's going on with the stock
market what's happening with the stock
market collapse of 2021
what's going on with bitcoin what are
you buying right now what are you
selling
where's the market gonna be headed how
do we make money right now this episode
oh my gosh that's a lot
we're gonna we got a lot to get into
holy smoke as well
you guys got how much my flapjacks how
much is that shirt this shirt uh so
okay guys i'll be honest i i wore this
to troll graham it's a 350
t-shirt from versace straight from italy
so got it at neiman marcus and i saw it
in my closet and i said
what am i gonna wear to get graham's
blood boiling because you guys know i
like to troll you every time last time i
came with starbucks
yeah the other time i had starbucks
delivered
with uber and then we had a tip and
everything and then this time i was like
well i'm not bringing starbucks i'll
just wear a versace shirt so
yeah that was the first thing i saw when
you were walking up i'm like why
yeah what's the point why did you buy
that shirt oh man
i don't know i think just for this
podcast honestly no you didn't
what went through your mind did you have
money that you had to get rid of that
day like it was a challenge like you
have to spend the money i think so
i just wanted to see does a 350 t-shirt
feel better than a
five dollar t-shirt and what i can
confidently tell you gentlemen
no it doesn't it feels the same exactly
could someone tell you that was fruit of
the loom and you would
be totally yeah i feel like it feels
like any other t-shirt i'll be honest
maybe
slightly more premium um but yeah it
honestly like
i don't feel any different with it on
i'll be honest so do you feel nervous
eating like a messy food in that like
spaghetti would you be
really like sweating i spilled dutch
bros on this before i got here
right across but lucky enough it's black
so it doesn't shine
dutch throws just like uh the lid kind
of leaked a little bit when i was taking
a drink and just went shh
oh my gosh did anyone ever tell you that
you should return the shirt
no one restore credit no no no one ever
told me yeah
i don't know what neiman's park uh
policy is on that i'll have to check on
that
isn't nordstrom's don't they have a
lifetime return policy
yeah i think you could return stuff to
nordstrom's without a receipt
without any proof of purchase you just
bring it back
and uh they hope that you tell them it's
like the honor system i believe with
neiman walker i appreciate that shout
out for jwn stock
you guys make any money on nordstrom i
did i bought
nordstrom at what i think is like ten
dollars a share eleven dollars a share
yeah i didn't put enough in because i
figured like oh it's nordstrom's like
when's the last time i shopped in
nordstrom's
a long time so i think i put in like
seven
grand or something sure enough it's like
tripled
yes and i'm looking at that i think
recently 45 dollars a share or so
no yes i thought it was like 30. it was
30 and then it just made a huge like
upward move i think it's
like 40. are you still buying nordstrom
i'm not buying nordstrom i still hold
some shares and unfortunately i sold
some shares in the 30s and now i'm
regretting it i'm like why didn't i hold
it
like everything i think i still got
about a little under 100k
probably in nordstrom wow but yeah it's
been a beast man it
like it was just 10 to 12 dollars back
in that was
a few months ago yeah it was like in the
fall of july yes
sure yeah like september i think you
could have picked up shares for 10 12
and now it's like 45 yeah
what's going on with the market right
now why is everything so expensive
yeah everything oh my gosh you know i
saw your video about the everything
bubble and uh yeah it does make me think
i mean there's just a
there's a lot of sloshing of money out
there there's people looking
to put money in different places there's
a lot of people that made a lot of money
in the market
in real estate almost everything and i
think just
that money kind of makes people want to
make more money and invest more money in
the market and i feel like
we've just had this massive like
flooding of money out there
and um it's made a lot of stocks get
really overvalued you know there's
definitely
people are willing to pay almost any
price for stocks right now i mean it's
it's it's substantial especially high
growth that's the type of stocks right
now that everybody wants to
you know i just spend twenty five
thousand dollars on pokemon cards okay
so i'm a prime example of people at too
much money right now
i just feel like there's something going
on right now in the market where
people feel like they have to invest
money out there and
cash is worthless right now and cash is
being devalued
and so let's buy stocks there's a lot of
people participating in the market
i'm talking the stock market
specifically that
these people wouldn't usually
participate in the stock market
like you really look at it and i'm i'm
watching people get in the market
and i'm talking about big money too i'm
not just talking about like joe who's
got like a thousand bucks and trying to
invest his first
thousand on it don't talk about joe that
way
hey i'm sorry joe sorry joe that wasn't
directed towards it was another joke
sorry there's gonna be a joe out there
who's watching this she's like i can't
believe jeremy called me out like that
he's like yeah but anyways no i'm
talking about like like people that
have like you know seven figures or even
more than that
and are investing like mad men in the
market and
it's like you know no names come to mind
but i'm thinking about some of these
people i'm like
you know some of these people didn't
usually participate in the market and
now they really want to flood some money
and so it's an interesting market we're
in right now
um and uh you know i'm just uh somebody
that's participating in it trying to
find deals
my main thing you know when it comes to
me i'm looking for the best deals
regardless if the market's uh a bubble
market
a bad market an overvalued market
undervalued market i'm looking for the
best deals
and um there's some of those out there
but they're they're few and far between
right now
how do you find a deal where do you look
walk us through the process
teach jack jack needs help
so i'll be honest like 75 or more than
75
of my stock picks now come from the
private discord chat in
in my private group like i'm getting i
i'm in a privileged position now where i
just get fed stocks and people like
what's your opinion on this stock what's
your opinion on this talk
and so sometimes it's annoying because
it's like it's too many dang stocks to
always think about
but sometimes i'm like oh my gosh like
they got a really good stock like
a lot of these stocks now are coming
from people because like in my private
group like these people are trained to
look at everything i look for in stocks
so now i have thousands of people
scouring
the like you know the the markets
looking for that next
gem the next nordstrom that next uh
revolve that next
up work that next tesla the next planet
or whatever stock you know
and so that's where it's kind of like an
unfair advantage i have now i feel like
because of that but before i would just
i would just like
look up lists of like s p 500 and um
do things like that or just like you
know going seeking alpha see what
they're talking about
sometimes i would just like watch cnbc
and look for tickers like coming across
the bar and like oh
there goes one i've never looked in that
stock before um
and just try to like be in the market
like like really like in the community
of stock market investing
and um and so that's where i picked up a
lot of a lot of names but nowadays like
i'll be honest like most of them are
coming from somebody in the discord chat
that
you know puts me on to something and
then i'm like oh you know this is a
really good one and next thing you know
i buy it
and what's your first step when you you
get a ticker let's say from a student in
your group what's your first step
like the fundamentals of the company
like really looking into what does this
company even do
and usually within
10 to 20 minutes i can tell if this is a
like
worth me going further sometimes there's
some companies and i'm just like well
you know that's just way over my head
like somebody could send me some
biopharmaceutical company
and i'm just like that's you know come
on that's just too much you know like
that i have no i have no um strength in
that area for instance
um i don't know that sector well or some
healthcare name like i don't know that
you know what company's going to grow
and what it's just that's too much for
me
so i'm looking for the fundamentals of
that business first and then we can go
from there
and um and then we'll go into the
financials and things like that but it's
always about the business first what do
they do
oh okay now we let me look in depth in
the business
now i have a rough idea of what they do
so
do you look up every ticker every ticker
in terms of what in terms of what's
recommended
or is it just like oh that that seems
kind of cool what's that one that
sounds like an awesome ticker symbol uh
sometimes i mean usually like you know
let's say somebody brings me a stock and
they're like oh yeah i'm buying blah
blah stocks usually they'll give me a
little bit of the case then i'll look
into that ticker
and see what the company does like the
profile like yahoo finance although it's
fallen off in recent years it's still
good for like
if somebody gives you a ticker and you
type it in like you can go to the
profile section
and get like in one paragraph like a
little bit of an understanding of that
company like what they do how they make
their money and then you can kind of go
from there
so yahoo finance is your preferred
method of research
for that initial profile part
of so let's say you you shared a ticker
with me let's say i had never looked
into tesla stock right and you're like
i'm looking in this electric vehicle
company tsla
i would go to yahoo finance i would type
in tsla i'd go to the profile section
and i would see like what they what do
they do like because that's gonna that's
gonna give me an idea of what this
company actually does
and then we can go from there and uh
figure out is this this worth me taking
further
then i might go to the investor
relations page for a company and start
doing some research there
and um you know we can go from there so
but first we have to thank our sponsor
grammarly recently we've had a few
projects going on around the house such
as installing the aquarium and
construction for the pool i used to
spend so much time drafting emails
requesting updates and coordinating
appointments with different companies
it was a nightmare it was really
important to me that my message came
across
clearly and concisely grammarly premium
gave me the tools i needed to save time
and effort when writing emails sending
out messages to friends and family
and pushing out team updates they offer
clarity suggestions that help me write
more concise sentences without
unnecessary or redundant words
and i especially like how grammarly
premium automatically suggests
alternative vocabulary that matches the
tone of my message
and with their desktop editor browser
plugin and mobile app it has never
been easier to revise my writing
wherever i go do more than just spell
check say what you really mean with
grammarly premium get twenty percent off
grammarly premium by signing up at
grammarly.com
iced coffee that's twenty percent off at
grammarly gr
dot com slash iced coffee thank you so
much grammarly for sponsoring this
episode and back to the podcast
it's too bad you're not able to set up a
screener that could go through the
discord
or go through the group and then pick
out how many times a certain ticker
symbol or company has been mentioned
and then see based on that if there's
any correlation to its price
oh that's a good idea we could do that
people have been doing that on reddit's
wall street bets
they've been coming up with these
incredible things that scour the entire
page
analyze every day how many times a
certain stock is mentioned and then
trade based on that
yeah i have a guy that could literally
probably do that on discord like he's
like a genius as far as like figuring
out
like uh different bots to set up and
things like that i i could have that's a
smart idea i might have to do that to be
honest
um you know but it's not like i can just
intuitively feel like
what stocks like a lot of retail people
are in because
if i get suggested this stock over and
over again this is like
stock that a lot of people are in like a
palantir is one of those stocks
uh pl tr i think's a ticker symbol
that's one of those stocks that like
i could just feel it like i don't even
need it to sift through discord like i
get so many suggestions about oh looking
to palantir more like what's your what's
your bold case on palantir
things like that what do you think of
palantir i'm still doing research on it
yeah that's one of those that's
a hard one to wrap your head around in
terms of
really understanding on a high level um
really understanding on a high level
like
what's their realistic opportunity in
the market
and um because a lot of people like you
know especially if you're new to the
market you just want to put money in a
stock
and so you know you could almost be fed
like any bull case and you're really
excited and you're like oh i got to buy
that stock they're going to grow
but it comes down to valuation also
that's another you know
part of the stock market and picking
good stocks like you got to look at the
valuation so what i'm trying to figure
out on palantir right now
is is palantir the type of stock that
is you know a good deal overall based
upon what their
true opportunity is not what you know
anybody else thinks they're opportunity
what i've researched with the company
what i
understand with the company so yeah it's
still a process
sometimes it takes weeks sometimes it
takes days to look into a company
sometimes it takes
i mean sometimes it takes months or
years you know for me to really get to
that point sometimes i never get there
so you know there's been times like that
in the past where like an amd stock for
instance yeah
yeah i remember when amd was two three
bucks a share and i looked at that stock
and
i was like wow man amd's really down but
i just couldn't wrap my head around it
and um obviously amd's like i don't even
know how high
d is it probably 90 now yeah i think
it's a little under 100 or something
yeah
and that was a stock i could have bought
but i just couldn't quite get there
with my head wrapped around it nvidia oh
my gosh
i trained this one guy on like how to
invest he's like another manager a quick
trip
when i lived in charlotte north carolina
came over the apartment i trained him on
everything
completely for free just a goodness in
my heart we like spent a whole day
and then he brought me a few stocks one
of them was nvidia this is when nvidia
was like
18 20 a share i was like i don't know
about that one because i just don't
quite
understand it nvidia obviously grew into
a giant and i don't know what nvidia is
today it might be
500 a share this is like you know five
or six years ago
might be six years ago now maybe seven
years ago but still like you know from
18 20 to 500 plus that's ridiculous man
do you have any regrets the regret's
usually the biggest one
oh my gosh there's so many i mean all my
regrets are always like
stocks i actually did understand on a
really high level but i didn't invest in
them
so you know stocks like amazon come to
mind where
amazon's not some incredibly hard
business model to understand
never bought it um there's a few other
companies i look at
and and then the other regret i have in
the stock market is like
a situation where i sell a stock too
early um
and then like the stock ended up being a
beast
and i'm just like wait why did i why did
i sell that stock again like did i
really need to get out of that stock
that fast so
those are usually my biggest regrets in
the market overall
i asked dave hansen this and this was
pretty
interesting to hear do you think that
you would be better off overall if you
had held on to every stock you've ever
bought
instead of selling oh that's really
interesting
um man that's a that's a tough question
because some of my companies got bought
out you know like some of them got
acquired by other companies so it's not
like i could have really like
you know i held on that stock for
instance like i remember king digital
got
bought out by uh activision blizzard
which king digital was basically they
came up with like the candy crush game
and some of those and there's just like
profit machines um and so some of those
companies get bought out so you can't
really hold on to those
but yeah ah most of them turned out
really well uh 90 i would say 90 95
percent
probably kept going up even after i sold
them um
maybe five to ten percent went down but
also
when it comes to selling it's like where
did you put the money because maybe you
put in
another stock that's actually much
better so for instance um
you know like i sold apple uh what was
that a year and a half ago two years ago
and apple's done amazing since then but
i put that money into tesla
where i thought it was going to be
better and obviously tesla's massively
outperformed apple so apple still did
great
and i could have just kept my money in
apple and but at the time i needed some
more money to invest in tesla so i put
in tesla and
tesla outperformed so um but yeah i mean
most of them have turned out pretty well
over time
so what do you think of uh kathy wood
in her new tesla prediction what did she
say
it was some absurd number yeah yeah so
they believe
uh on a bear case tesla's going to be
1500
a share in 2025 and right now it's like
600 650 so that that's our bear case
their like medium case like they're like
one they think the realistic case
that one is at three thousand dollars a
share
okay and so a little less than a five x
from here by 2025
and then their bowl case is actually
four thousand dollars a share
so and they do have some cases that are
above that but that's so
they believe basically fifteen hundred
dollars to four thousand dollars in 2025
tesla stock will be how is it possible
so they have them doing some
unbelievable revenue numbers
they believe that tesla's going to be
selling worst case scenario
5 million cars a year in 2025
best case scenario 10 million cars in
2025.
now as a tesla bull that's really hard
for me even to wrap my head around that
because keep in mind tesla
last year sold about a half million cars
so to go
to 5 million to 10 million like we're
already in 2021
to do that by 2025 she's more bullish
than i am
and arkansas is more bullish than i am
how many cars do
like honda sell toyota honda i don't
know off top my head i know toyota i
think is number one and they usually do
if i recall i think it's around 10
million a year
around 10 million a year so she thinks
that tesla's going to be selling as much
as
uh toyota yeah but the big thing is by
2025 yeah
see like i've always imagined like 20 30
okay
we can talk about 2030 maybe they're the
biggest maybe they're doing 10 million
and 20 million cars
but 2025 like that happened like you
know years go fast man like you were
already in 2021
2025 to get to from 500k
to 5 million to 10 million i mean you're
gonna need to
you know ramp up production in a massive
way you're gonna need
crazy massive adoption around the world
basically to hit those type of numbers
in that quick amount of time so
yeah i mean she's more bullish than i am
i'm really bullish on tesla but
my numbers are further out than than her
numbers are so in in ark invest in
general
let's be clear it's not just kathy wood
that comes up with these numbers they do
models
uh tasha keeney over there and um so i
don't want to say like it's just like
kathy would be in like ah this is what i
believe it's like arc invest like the
whole
you know etf so what's to stop them from
just making stuff up
i mean kiss cuz she could say like my
bull case is
ten thousand dollars a share the price
of tesla starts going up like you know
ten percent oh what did i do okay so hit
it once there you go whoa that is cool i
had no idea so i bought this on amazon
it was like 40 bucks and i could not
figure out how to turn it on
but i set it down on the table and
turned on i was like okay maybe there's
like a wire loose or something like that
and then then i adjusted it and it kept
getting brighter and i thought like uh
crap like it's broken it's like it won't
stay at the same level
it took me probably like 10 minutes to
figure out that anywhere you touch on
that
i don't know what it is but it turns up
or down the brightness
that was cool man press it again look
whoa
for 40 bucks yeah oh that's magical yeah
i've never seen that before
wow ah i'm just kidding
that's cool oh my goodness all right
yeah kathy wood
is she crazy ad break
but first we have a quick word from our
sponsor fubotv if you're one of the 80
million americans who are fed up with
paying high cable prices and dealing
with shady cable companies well there is
finally an alternative that gives you
the cable tv experience
at half the cost it's called fubotv
fubotv comes with over 100 of your
favorite channels including complete
coverage of all of your favorite sports
with all local broadcasters
all major sports league networks nfl red
zone espn
abc cbs and many more i'm sure there are
plenty of you out there who know how
difficult it is to get access to these
channels and all the weird and expensive
packages you have to buy from cable tv
graham when did you get in here dude
whatever anyways
plus you can record your favorite games
and shows on fubotv's cloud dvr
and watch anywhere on any device you
could save
so much money by making this simple
switch well that's a great point graham
and fubotv is easy to try it just takes
two minutes to sign up and start
streaming
all of your favorite cable channels sign
up for a risk free trial of fubotv and
get
15 off your first month by going to
fubotv.com
iced coffee thank you so much fubotv for
sponsoring this episode and back to the
podcast
yes oh gosh okay so um
yeah i mean you know we should always
view things from a context of it you
know she's obviously been buying tesla
heavy
and tesla's the name that made
kathy wood and arkan vest obviously
right over all the other names by far
and away like if you know arc invest you
know kathy what is because of tesla and
her predictions and things like that
right
they've been buying the stock it is
really important for arc invest
for tesla stock to go up let me be very
clear about that over the coming years
the reason being is if tesla stock
doesn't go up people's
you know not everybody like some people
are gonna ride or die with her in the
etf but there's
been a lot of people that have jumped on
that bandwagon who
is because kathy wood nor confess
they're the hot thing on the block on
wall street right now
and so if tesla starts going down
performing badly
there's going to be a lot of people that
pull their money out of that etf
and then you kind of get in the
situation you got less and less money
going in you know arc might have to sell
more tesla stock
it makes the stock go down even more it
creates more disbelief in it in the
short term
and so there's i could understand that
argument about
you know them wanting to keep tesla
stock inflated or go up a lot
because let's be honest the more tesla
goes up
not just does it help arcs returns it
helps arc's brand
it helps you know kathy woods brand and
things like that for that etf
and it'll keep money flowing in so they
can continue to buy tesla stock and
other stocks out there
so you know i don't want to say that's
why they're doing it or something like
that or why they have a big price target
because they've always had big price
targets it's just like
you should at least like understand that
it is a possibility
so i have a feeling when people make
bold claims like that
if it doesn't pan out their reputation
isn't as damaged as one would think
because a lot of people kind of just
forget that they ever made that claim in
the first place
yeah i would say so you know some people
will definitely you know
hold it against them for a long time but
yeah there's some truth to that for
instance like the short seller and i
don't want to call it the short seller
community but like
the the people that are always like the
market's gonna crash fifty percent
you know i remember you referenced harry
dent recently oh
gosh he said too the market was gonna
crash like 90 something percent
yeah in one of kevin's videos yeah i
mean
so you have those individuals that year
after year after year it's like this is
the end this is the end this is the end
and then you know people just forget
about it and then when the market gets
rough they
you know are like applauded it's like oh
they're so smart but um
yeah so there's some truth to that i've
definitely seen it with those people
that are just like
always negative and it's like buy gold
and things like that so
yeah i could see that so you'll buy
stocks that are overvalued
will i buy stocks that are overvalued
not usually
if i'm looking out if i'm running
valuations
three years out five years out and it
still looks like a rip
off i won't buy it it's just flat out
like it doesn't matter how much i love
the company if it looks like a rip off
even
on three year out and five year out
numbers like i'm good
even if i love the company um so i don't
mind sometimes paying a premium for
stock but it has to
make sense over the next few years like
i have to be able to like formulate the
numbers and be like oh i see how they
can
fulfill this valuation over time you
look fit man
oh thanks man i'm trying to make
progress i'm trying to get a six-pack by
summer that's my
you could be you know jared of subway
you could be
the the jared of uh tattooed chef yeah
and be like this is all because of
tattooed chef
i gotta say the cauliflower like i was
really looking into it i was like you
know and that's our main ingredient in
those products i was like dang man
that's
actually a really healthy thing but also
like when you spend 350
on versace shirts you got to make sure
they look decent you can't be you don't
have them
having rolls or whatever man what's up
what's your workout
routine what's my workout routine what
are you doing yeah i mean sometimes i'll
do sprints
um when i'm in arizona i'll actually
play a lot of basketball uh there's a
in our community there's a nice like
basketball and hoop and no one ever
plays down there so
i'll like record some videos and then i
just go down there like three four
o'clock
shoot some hoop run around uh maybe do
some sprints after that something like
that
um and so yeah that's kind of i do a
little more intense workouts and
probably a lot of people i do
um have like a boxing bag at the
henderson house i haven't been hitting
it lately though i've been really lazy
as far as that goes
um but yeah so you know some of that
type of stuff so
graham and him graham and i have been
working out recently yeah oh man there's
a little gym in this community gym
opened up
oh it did just opened up yep so when you
when you come in are you gonna work out
with us
i might that would be something we do
today like it's a daily thing really
yeah do you guys really good what do you
guys do in there
well waits we get we get jacked yeah
we get really big yeah oh man it's only
been a few days
so we're still getting into this that
first day was so rough so i
probably took like five months off from
going to the gym entirely
and got back and did my normal workout
routine maybe like
you know 70 of what i would usually do i
felt a little weak but it wasn't bad
that next day i could not move my like
base my entire body
was just it hurt so much and i went to
bed
and i'd never had this before but i woke
up my arm
was just i couldn't move my arm and it
was so painful that i thought like
i might have to take an advil for this i
couldn't sleep i thought there was
something wrong
and like i couldn't move my arm beyond
like that because it hurts so
badly did you uh where did you ever your
muscles ever like involuntarily just
start like
vibrating during the workout yes
during the workout like you get the like
you're doing the chest press and your
arms are going like
oh yeah that's not really what i mean
but yeah there's a there's a separate
one where just like
your leg will just start like to do oh
no no no i'm not spasming
oh really okay yeah that happens to me
sometimes if i do a really serious work
really yeah and it's like they say
that's your muscle growing i don't know
that's your muscles i'll be honest
but yeah no it's crazy man when you work
out like that it's just a
ton of little tiny tears in your muscle
and then you gotta build it back
stronger
tattooed yeah it's weird how that works
it is it's it's you're breaking down the
muscle and then it has to grow back even
thicker to compensate for that yeah so
it's like imagine adding scar tissue on
top of your muscle
every single time you break it it gets
thicker you break it it gets thicker it
doesn't sound healthy
no it doesn't like when you put it like
that yeah like that's really like when
you see a bodybuilder like that they've
just torn
every muscle in their body multiple
times and it's had to compensate for
that
yeah it's really what it comes down it's
weird i can't work out the way i used to
i will say that and it's
not because i don't want to it's just
like like i get hurt or something man
i'm just a weakling now
like my back like i got a herniated disc
in my back last year
uh i did a serious workout not that long
ago and then my foot i think i
i got like plantar fasciitis which is
kind of like a situation in your heel
and i'm just like dang man i'm just i'm
only 31 but i'm like dang
like i have so much respect for like
professional athletes
that can keep performing at a top level
at their sports at like like i watch
lebron he's like i don't know 38
years or i don't know 37 38 he's still
dunking on people's heads i'm like my
goodness
tom brady just won a super bowl he's
like 45.
i like i have so much respect for those
guys i'm like how do they do it i'm
watching myself at 31 and i'm like i
didn't put
anything close on my body like those
guys have it's crazy man
even tiger woods still going oh you got
an entrance you have no accident
you hear that yeah when recently
last week it was a bad one man i mean he
has to be seen i mean he survived
but he it's strange so what happened he
was going downhill
uh in in newport beach i believe and
just he lost control of his car and went
through the center median
and then went off the side of the cliff
and the car
like tumbled around so they got him out
of the car
he's he survived but it's unclear if
he's going to be able to play golf again
that's terrible yeah and so people are
wondering like how do you lose
control of the car yeah some people are
thinking you fell asleep they're like
that
it's the way that accident i guess
looked looks like a common like where
you fall asleep
driving and all sudden you wake up
midway through and you're already too
late
right and it didn't seem like it was
speeding
down this this hill like he lost control
of the car because that's so
yeah i don't know so we'll we'll see
yeah right
hopefully everything is what yeah
hopefully he's all right
yeah do you think that the way that you
research stocks and financial statements
and stuff like that
translates to other portions of your
life like like analyzing the nutritional
facts of
like a food or something like that uh
maybe i don't know i was probably into
nutrition way before stocks but i don't
know maybe
um i will say like you know stocks you
know all the research i do in the
companies because i
have been involved in like investing i i
think it makes me better
at like business overall um because i
just understand like you know
like you just you learn so much from
these companies like i'm doing super
in-depth research i'm like oh that's how
they're making this money oh that's how
they're getting this gross margin
you list on conference calls and you
pick up on so many different things you
know just business related that
i think it really like helps me out big
time um
when it comes to like if i'm gonna make
moves out there and things like that so
what was that a weird question no
oh okay that's a fun question i was
thinking about what to say afterwards
and
oh we i was hoping you would just keep
talking and then
by what's your option strategy like
right now like are you doing anything
yeah i got one
option open right now one call option so
what i like to do is i like to play
um options that are basically two years
or more in advance usually so what i
like to do is september october uh
between september and november of each
year
options come out that are like a little
over two years in advance like two years
in like three months okay
and so what i like to do is i like to
say is there any stock i have a lot of
conviction in
over the next two years and whatever and
um that i really really believe in
that is going to go up a lot and then i
look at the option prices and sometimes
i buy them
uh so the only option play i have open
right now is dropbox
and it is up over 100 we've done very
very well on that one yeah it's been
tremendous
uh you bought one call no i got i bought
21 000
worth of calls and i think there were i
don't know between 45 and 55 right now
um and so we're doing really well in
that one but that was one of those that
i'm like
there's just no way i can't you know
when i bought those there's just no way
i couldn't see dropbox like being a
beast over the next two plus years
and so i was like i'll throw 21 000
worth in in the call options and
you know i don't do a lot of of option
moves because it does put you with that
like
time situation i don't like that where
you it has to go to a certain price by a
certain date
you're going to lose a bunch of money
and so you know that i'm not a faint of
but
my gosh there's a lot of money to be
made but um i mean the problem is man a
lot of people lose money when options
i'll be honest
there's there's certain individuals i
have one that's going to be a new coach
for us like they consistently make
profits
but they're not doing the type of risky
strategies like even my strategy even
though it's two years out is still
considered risky because those can
expire worthless
you can do a lot of different strategies
like selling covered calls and things
like that
that i don't feel like getting into
right now because i don't feel like
explaining it
because it's i'm like um my brain's not
there i need a whiteboard to actually
explain
options in detail but there's some
strategies like that that you can really
make consistently pretty good money in
and there's there's other ones as well
that you know of jack because you're the
options master and then you're gonna
come here but the expert at one percent
per trade yeah hey man you're one
percent sometimes
yeah there's different they're just
different strategies out there man but
uh
you know that's um yeah i don't do a lot
of those moves i'm most the time just
like let me just buy the dang stock and
sometimes i'll look into far out like
calls
and then i'm like okay i have to pay
this i need to go let let me just buy
the stock
forget trying to mess around with that
so what do you think of the whole
gamestop fiasco
oh my gosh where do you start with that
i mean i don't have a strong opinion on
it i mean i know a lot of people are
super opinionated on it
it's actually i'm surprisingly not
opinionated on it
um you know i don't know i don't have
that it's funny because i'm the stock
market guy but i don't have
a strong opinion on that it's like um it
is what it is i
i don't know like you know it's not a
stock i'm interested in
it's not a bad stock but it's not a
stock that i'm like i gotta buy that
stock
um i think it's good in the respect that
it gets a lot of people into the market
a lot of people are like ah let me start
buying stocks and
at least like you know sometimes you
have to get people into the market
through different
means right not everybody is going to be
like me and like
super like go-getter like i can't wait
to start looking into companies i want
to be the next warren buffett like not
everybody wants to do that
some people you have to drag them into
the stock market through different
avenues right
and so i think a situation like that
gets a lot of people excited
and so from that perspective i'm happy
you know
the whole rest of it it's like you know
it is what it is i don't really
have a strong opinion on it to be honest
so
does it worry you that it's still
trading above 200
a share it's a 15
billion valuation right now for gamestop
yeah
yeah i wouldn't say it worries me um
i mean whether it goes up a bunch or
down a bunch you know i think
people that are really been buying that
are prepared to lose their money for the
most part
or see the value go down or something
like that um
and i think they understand that risk i
think the same way
you know somebody you know we live in
vegas right so i mean somebody goes down
the sports book like they could win a
bunch of money but they also understand
oh man
i'm this might cope this might go bad
and i might lose everything
gamestop i don't think that's the type
of stock you lose everything in though
let me be very clear
it's just whether gamestop goes up over
the coming years or whether it goes down
let's say 50 over the next few years i
think that's the real question with
gamestop
i don't look at that business model and
say that's going to zero it also is hard
for me to see that going to a thousand i
mean i've seen people saying
game stops going to a thousand dollars
we've seen a thousand
five thousand yeah and ten times ten
thousand dollars
yeah yeah there's been people on reddit
being like forty thousand dollars it's
going to hit
40 grand we just got a whole everyone's
paying 40 thousand dollars for this yeah
yeah you know people just we'll talk
crazy
people go bankrupt before that stop it
was the idea that it was over
shorted by the inside and they'd have to
buy it at whatever they wouldn't
they would they don't have to buy it
they because they were locked into
contracts
no they would just listen we're we're
done
listen that's what's gonna happen they
can't
just invent money out of nowhere to pay
for something that they can't afford
they would go bankrupt they would just
go bankrupt right exactly yeah and then
nobody gets their 40 grand
yeah they're just gonna say i'm sorry
we're not playing in this game anymore i
don't like this game i knew somebody
eric cartman of that be like all right
screw you guys i'm going home
yeah i know i i i knew someone who was
so convinced in gamestop
that they had everything that they owned
except their fully paid off house
but every last penny aside from that
into gamestop it was nearly a million
dollars
in 800 call options that expired
yesterday
oh what what what are they wow so they
so they put in they had like they i
think it was like 80 grand
or something like that and it went up to
to like 900 000
and they held over the weekend two weeks
ago
into monday of this week with like a
million dollars in 800
calls so they would be able to buy
gamestop at 800
per share wow yesterday and
obviously it didn't hit it so what
happens to just the money i don't know
if he exited his position but i know for
a fact
if he if he did exit his position i'm
sure he at least lost like
50 60 70 percent people you're hanging
out with
i was telling him that was a terrible
idea i was telling him that's a no-go
but who is this guy
his name's crispy stocks he's in the
mentorship group are you serious
i told him not to do it yeah i said i
said dude you you turned like 80 grand
in
into nearly a million get out and jebe
was telling him too he was like dude you
should get out of that like you've
already made so much money he's like oh
i'm convinced it's going to ten thousand
dollars a share
jeez why didn't i hear about this
because it was on a tuesday you weren't
there that sounds like an interesting
video
wow no i i we could actually have like a
segment with him on or something he has
a youtube channel and he's like
he was so convinced he said he was fully
prepared
to go work out wendy's like if if it
expired worthless
be totally fine going working at wendy's
restarting
that's just greed that's greed though
when you when you turn 80 into how much
was it worth at the point it was like a
million
that's just greed he said he was going
to be worth 10 million was his
projection
mommy what could you do yeah hey man we
live in vegas i'm sure somebody on the
strip tonight's gonna
turn some silly small amount of money
into some
stupid amount yeah and then they're
gonna get calm to that night and then
they're gonna stay another night and
they're gonna lose it all you know what
i mean it's just
you know i know gamblers want gamble
it's just that's the hardest part i keep
looking at like a hand of blackjack and
i'm like well if i put
25 on this hand and i just keep pushing
and i keep doing this for like 10 hands
in a row
that's it you know i'm set i can't
believe the last
not to change the subject but i've been
the last two times i went to
the encore i didn't lose money
it's a miracle and one of the times was
with you i don't go that often but when
i have
it's actually it was probably twice in
the last six months and that's a miracle
because you know when i go
every single time you manage to lose
money yeah not even doing anything risky
it's not like you're making stupid bets
like i lost
you're betting the same as everybody
else but somehow you always lose money
oh gosh i know it's like i go there
wanting to lose
man but yeah somehow the last two times
i didn't but anyways to get back to that
whole gamestop situation man it's
it's a messy situation there's no doubt
um we'll see what happens with it over
time
you know um yeah you know
man i don't know it's i don't know what
else to say about it honestly you know
it's just does it work
see i'm worried that that's the state of
the market right now like that's not a
sign
that we're in a healthy market i mean
i'm sure every stock is going to have
little pumps and
but for that to happen on such a wide
scale worries me that like there's no
way that's healthy
there's no way that we're in an economy
right now that should support something
like that yeah
yeah it's just it's what's going on at
the moment man
yeah it is it is a little worrisome like
you're talking about people so flush
with cash
i think i'm the perfect example of
buying the car like i would rather
buy the car than keep money in a bank
account because i think the car is safer
than cash
and i'm not like a conspiracy theorist
about anything like i'm not like
too extreme on that yeah so i'm i'm
thinking like if i'm doing that
how many other people are doing the same
it's true yeah how many other people are
that
flush with cash right now to throw
everything they have into the market
yeah no it's a really good point i mean
there's a lot of people making
money from the gamestop situation
different ways i do have a friend he uh
if i recall he sold
some um 800 strikes
that expire in april and he got like 31
dollars premium
so he and i think he did four contracts
so he's going to clear like 12 000
and as long as gamestop doesn't go to
you know 800
plus by april i don't remember well even
if it does he's selling them for 800
a share which is like yeah yeah so i
mean he's looking good i mean he could
get into trouble if maybe you know i
don't know the stock really goes crazy
but
um yeah i mean he's gonna yeah he's
gonna make like twelve thousand dollars
in
a fairly low risk situation right i
would say there's probably a one percent
or maybe even less than a one percent
chance of that happening
to make twelve thousand dollars like hmm
that's pretty attractive
that's wild yeah people are willing to
pay almost any price for those options
on gamestop just because the whole might
go to a thousand soon or something like
that
so what do you think about the stock
fisker
fisker i haven't looked into in depth
yet you should i've looked into
lucid but not fisker yet why not i just
haven't had a chance
okay yeah i mean it's just like a
massive backlog of stocks i always have
to look look into fisker
fisker what did you see there i just was
i i'm not a stock guy
i liked fisker back when they first came
out with the fiskar karma this was like
2011 2012.
and uh i thought i thought they were
gonna win against tesla i thought they
had
they had a cooler car this is before the
the self-driving
whatnot they had a cooler looking car
the problem with the car was that they
caught on fire oh so
so and then they had some financial
issues they weren't able to fix the cars
they went bankrupt then another company
bought them
okay kept them but then they're now
remaking these cars
wow so i don't know i think there's
potential there they got a really cool
car they're coming out with a few other
options
like on fire hot stuff no no it hasn't
it's been
underappreciated it's been trading
between 12
and like 23 24 for
gosh how many months now i think just
being a part of the ev sector
like that stock could blow up i know you
know that stock could blow up like on
fire
like fire yeah no it could be a neo yeah
yeah
honestly interesting yeah i looked into
lucid so far and that's about it oh
obviously neo and some of those
companies but yeah i haven't looked into
fisker so yeah i might have to take a
peek there and see if there's something
there
obviously that's been a space that's
been so hot like yeah
just everybody wants the next tesla the
next hustle the next tesla
people are really desperate for it man
but uh yeah there's been some stocks
have gotten hammered in that space i
don't know how much you guys you know
keep up with it but like
workhorse oh my gosh that stock fell i
think 60 70 percent like in a snap of
fingers because they didn't get some
contract with
usps that they were supposed to like my
gosh that's devastating um
lordstown motors i think that one's down
i want to say 50
60 yeah that's a weird situation there
um and so some of those stocks have just
gotten absolutely obliterated
never mind like here's the thing if the
nasdaq goes down a bunch more like you
know i'm talking like a ton
i'm talking like 10 that's going to mean
tesla's down
20 to 30 percent that's gonna mean some
of those other stocks are down
even more than that so i don't think
that's the thing people understand about
the market
and um you know obviously if everything
goes great nasdaq keeps going up nasa
keeps pumping
tesla's doing great right and a lot of
the higher risk plays are going to do
great
but all it takes is nasda like if the
nasdaq falls 10
next week which probably isn't going to
happen but let's just say it
hypothetically did
tesla's down 20 30 plus percent in that
amount of time
easily because tesla just goes down a
lot more and the market goes down
usually 2x to 3x
on the flip side if the market does
great tesla goes up 2x to 3x more
and then all those other higher risk
plays in a tesla get hit
even harder and so some of those can go
down 30 40
with only a 10 pullback in the nasdaq
and that's
that's i think sometimes what people
don't understand that's why it's really
dangerous
to go on margin with those sorts of
stocks
and i don't think that's what people
understand sometimes they they just
think about the upside
like oh i'm gonna margin out extra money
in these and um
really what they're not realizing is man
it's true
you know it can go south fast and when
it goes south fast man next thing you
know you have margin calls and it
gets messy quick do you think we're
running out of growth
like what what more can contribute to
this
because i feel like we just did the
stimulus package we've already somewhat
priced in a full recovery
we're getting people vaccinated what
else is there to
boost this further yeah and now it's
going to come down to corporate earnings
i feel like from here now as the economy
opens back up
all eyes are going to go on to earnings
and for the next
probably two to six quarters i would say
and now it's like
now we're going to be into a stage where
it's like prove me stock market like
prove to me what you're going to do like
prove to me companies like
what your eps is and things like that
prove to me that you can justify these
valuations
if corporate earnings are extremely
strong throughout 2021
there's no doubt we could have more
potential upside but that's what it's
really going to come down to the
earnings have to be strong
they have to justify these valuations
and
and then people will continue to buy the
stocks right if if
if you know earnings are bad and it's
like oh this wasn't everything we're
cracked up to be then it's like oh
okay that's not looking good so yeah
we'll see
do you use margin in your account a
little bit yeah because i got a 1.55
percent
now i negotiated with fidelity thanks to
kevin shout out kevin
yeah if you see this video which you
probably won't because you record videos
all day but if you do
kevin watches everything yeah i know you
would be surprised
he's one of the first people to comment
on almost uh every video on the main
channel wow
kevin if you're watching comment i'm
watching this
no no i'm watching this one two
three there we go i'm watching this one
two three so he's got to be precise
about it i like that i like that but
yeah the ultimate test
yeah anyways shout out to kevin for
giving me that lower margin rate so yeah
i will
um but thing i like to do is i like to
always make sure i'm not overextending
myself
um or anything like that um you know
because
like i said you can get it can get
dangerous fast another thing i like to
do is like to focus on companies
buying companies that i feel like are
undervalued that there's very limited if
i'm gonna buy a margin it has to be with
stocks that have
very limited downside for me you know
like so for instance
some stocks that i bought some on margin
of recently would have been
walgreens put some money margin money in
that when it was like 40 a share roughly
and i looked at that one and i'm like
okay like what's the chances that one
falls
30 percent even 20 percent i feel like
extremely minimal
and obviously it's done pretty well uh
corsair gaming i've been doing a little
margin money in that one recently
because that one's down to
a 4p of like 20. so i feel like there's
a little potential short-term weakness
there
um around potentially a situation where
there's a lock-up coming this upcoming
week so
maybe there's a little more sell-off for
the next few weeks or something like
that but then i feel like from there's
upside
um margined a little bit in tattooed
chef where i feel like there's
limited downside there because it's like
a 1.7 billion dollar mark cap with 200
mil cash and crazy growth
so yeah i i really have to feel
protected
if i'm gonna do anything on margin and i
have to have the money to back it
so i went a hundred percent margin
in my robinhood account just in my
robinhood account okay
uh right like in during the dip not at
the bottom
but as it was going down wow i tried to
time it
good for you though you probably did
well no i didn't do well because
because this was paper hands yeah no no
no no no no
he loses 200 he's like so things didn't
go as bad as they could have gone
so as it was going down i bought like i
want to say like 120 shares of apple
okay like as it was going down and i
bought uh some more palantir
some other just like random stocks some
neo and stuff like that but
it still continued to go down but once i
bought them
i hedged my position with some covered
calls
okay so although it did continue to go
down my options had value
they they went up in value and my
options actually
shielded me from all of the downsides
you're talking about the march 2020
crash or this most recent this most
recent oh okay i was a little confused
okay cool
no no yeah i was i was thinking you're
talking about that one i'm like well
done man like
no i went down a lot but it it could
have hurt a lot worse had i not
i had that position i i was so scared to
buy stocks in march 2020
we talked about regrets earlier yeah i
was really i didn't buy anything i
started buying in april
so i didn't get the exact bottom
unfortunately in a lot of stocks because
i was like
you know i was really confused on like
like you know when have we ever shut off
money velocity and like how does all
this play out
but man like i remember i remember
seeing wynn
at 35 dollars a share one day i remember
seeing uber
uber stock and i think was 14 a share
and um yeah just some of those pricing
and i had cash but i was really scared
so i started buying again in april when
we
like you know we had kind of started
going up again and i was watching what
was happening and they were talking
about stimulus and i was like okay
let me start entering but man some of
those prices i think was march 23rd was
the very lows
oh my gosh man congrats to anybody that
bought march
23rd 2020 you did well for yourself that
was a scary time man
yeah i bought the the issue that with me
is
i started buying too early okay so i
started buying the beginning of march
uh a little so this is just like after
the 15
dip bought in a little bit thinking i'm
a genius
i'm a genius look at all this fool's
over there buying in
and it kept dropping and i'm like okay
let me just
take a step back i don't want to just
like invest everything
and then i about april that's when i
started going
going in but i missed that bottom
kind of coming up yeah that was that was
definitely you know the scariest time
i've ever been in the stock market
because i mean it came out of nowhere
once in a hundred year health event and
then it was just like
you know that's just something you you
know you can't prep for it it's just you
have to go through it to really
experience it and things like that
i think one of the biggest things is
like i've always learned is like just to
keep the faith
you know in one of those situations that
is going to work out you know you don't
know how it's going to work out but it's
going to work out and
um yeah jay powell man you can't stop
that man he's unstoppable
do you think they're basically they've
gotten the market to a point where
they're not going to let it fail
they're not they're not going to let it
drop more than like 30 40 percent
that's that's kind of almost the way i
feel sometimes i mean
yeah i feel like they're really really
scared um to really like
let the market go down in any
significant way
and um yeah yeah i do kind of almost
feel like that to be honest
i do it's um you know and it kind of
almost makes you feel
it almost makes you want to feel
fearless in the market it almost it
makes you want to say
let me throw everything let me go all in
on margin you know let's go
hauling on calls because you almost feel
like
it can't go that bad because they're
going to save the day like they'll just
pump some money out there and things
like that
but the interesting thing about this
last time was they had the excuse to
pump money out there because it was a
once in a hundred year health event
and because the government forced the
economy to close
in states and you know federal
government and everything like that
so when you when you come from that
context it's like okay you can do
everything
but you know i mean it still does you
kind of think like what happens if we
had a traditional recession
um where it's not because of a one 100
year event can they still get away with
the money flood out there there's
unemployment i
i do think so okay yeah because then
they would be worried about the entire
economy collapsing
lending drying up people are losing
their jobs or losing their homes they
can't they can't have that
yeah no that's a good point yeah that's
a really good point and then
the other thing is with this whole you
know most recent situation i think
now they're gonna have a lot more
discussions not just you know
soon but over the coming years about
like you know should we start sending a
thousand dollars
to everybody that makes under 100k every
month i think those are going to be
discussions that are probably going to
be the most uh
heard yeah in american history which is
going to be interesting so if you don't
make 100k a month
then you get it
[Laughter]
100k a year okay yes your face is out at
200
000 a month oh and for families
it's for families earning up to four
hundred thousand dollars a month
there are people that make under 100k a
month are you telling me
if that's normal no oh gosh
yeah i know anyways but yeah that should
be interesting we'll see what happens
so what do you think about ubi
for everyone earning under 100 000 a
month struck struggling i mean you know
obviously it it would probably benefit
the economy well
um you know i am not a professional
economist and i'll never pretend to be
one and i'm also not a
government official and so i don't know
what that would do to budgets i don't
know
if that would create a messy situation i
know obviously there's um
you know there's a lot of folks that
feel that
if we just give money for free that it's
taking things too far
right uh you know some folks out there
are okay with
you know food stamps or unemployment
yeah yeah unemployment or let's say even
a situation where
um you get uh free health care you get
your health care taken and i've been on
that system before like you know there
was
you know when i didn't have much money
like i had to be um
man there was this weird like rash that
happened on my body and i had to go to
the hospital for a few days and this is
when i was working at walgreens making
like 8.25 an hour so i didn't have
uh you know health insurance and i
didn't have any money obviously
so you know that was like 20 i was
either 19 000 or 23 000
in bills right and i didn't have to
worry about it like the state just paid
that state of arizona because i made
under
a certain amount of money and so you
know if i had to actually pay that debt
at that time that would have been
devastating that would have been
super bad you like that just wasn't in
the financial position so
you know people are okay with that they
say okay you can eat you can you can
have health care
but where a lot of folks have issues
is if you're just giving straight up
money to folks that they can spend it on
whatever
and um you know i can understand those
concerns and i can understand the
concerns coming from the other side that
say hey man i need money
um so i i mean i understand both sides
it's gonna it's gonna be a messy
situation
to ever get it passed i feel like um
because of that reason it's like are you
changing
you know a lot of folks that feel like
are you changing the fabric of the
united states
um in what we mean and
what we represent if you just start
giving people
money for free as some folks would would
say and so yeah i mean
i don't know i i have no opinion on it
really i'm like
you know i would love to see studies
that are done um i think this
this whole situation is going to be
interesting like if the economy
does tremendous and not just in terms of
like the short term but i'm talking over
the next several years
i think there's going to be a lot of
push for this potentially being a thing
out there
i think if the economy doesn't really
benefit that much and it just feels like
assets
i think people are gonna say that was
that was not a good idea you know or
things like that so
yeah i'm watching it we'll see how it
plays out
yeah what do you guys think if you want
to share your
opinion on it yeah go ahead jump in the
fire
yeah give me i was just collecting my
thoughts here you first
i think that well okay i don't want to
say i think that because i don't really
know what i think but what makes sense
to me
is that there is like a basic standard
of living
right where obviously like you can
afford the the things that you are
required to live
okay right uh i i don't want to be like
political or anything
that's really not my thing yeah i would
listen
where i feel there's so much government
waste there's so much money that's
wasted i have a feeling we could
probably afford it as is
if we just cut all the crap i think
there's so much just administration and
so many just big salaries required just
to just to distribute every little thing
and like
you know check every i think this is
just a lot of waste i think if we could
find a way to expedite it we could
probably actually
still do that but save a lot of money in
the process and cut
other things that maybe aren't as
efficient and just straight up to send
everyone a thousand bucks
but cut out a lot of the other things
that just are no longer needed because
of that
i agree i actually was looking into it
and the city of santa monica
makes over or sorry it makes nearly 1
billion
dollars in revenue every year and if you
go to the city of santa monica
it is not very nice like it's it's not
very clean
there's nicer than venice well
sure like there is like a little bit of
poverty and stuff like that
and it's not like the nicest area but
considering how much money that they're
making you would expect that they would
be able to
handle some of those things yeah you
know what i mean increase the standard
of living for the residents
but interesting they they don't jack is
angry that he gets parking tickets i get
so many santa monica
so many of them and you know what each
of them
73 73 73 i looked it up
and from the like the the parking
enforcement
i think it was like some ridiculous like
15 million dollars every year yeah
successful business yeah like
it's absolutely i know so
yeah i think that there is there is a
lot of government waste i think
undeniably
there is a lot yes santa monica was bad
they
man so they charge you for uh
like a rent control fee so if you have a
multi-unit in santa monica they charge
you
every year to basically be a part of a
of a registry
where they just monitor what you're
charging the tenant
and they're monitoring the rent
increases so what i found crazy is that
in santa monica the maximum rent
increase
is either three percent per year or 44
dollars per year whichever is greater
yeah that's not much so if you're
renting a place in santa monica for like
let's say eight
thousand dollars a month the maximum
rent increase every year
is 44 44 bucks
and you have to pay for them to oversee
all of that so i so when when i got my
place
uh they automatically bill you for that
right that rent control fee
even though i was living there they
build me for it and then i have to go
and prove that
i'm living there for them to refund me
so i actually did all this work and i
got like
my 200 bucks back because i just had a
principle i'm like there's no way
they're collecting that fee for me
wow my gosh it's running very poorly
yeah
jeez yeah man i know we
thought about starting um a life
insurance business recently and
you know i had like the lawyers looking
into it and things like that and you
know when we got to
so first off if you want to do insurance
you have to go like state by state
it's not like you just get like it's
it's complicated and so i was like well
what about california
no no no not california like
there's so many easier places to do
business than in california but
anyways you know yeah it's it's uh you
know i don't want to speak on it because
i've never lived there i've just
i've heard stories from a lot of
different people that it's just it's
it's a hard place to do business
it's a hard place to do a lot of things
so yeah
yeah the only thing for me with vegas
vegas is very much like
do whatever you want mm-hmm i like that
but it's the hoas
oh h o a's ah geez i
i didn't realize there are two hoa and
it's my fault for not understanding
we're an hoa within an hoa and
i don't realize that yes i thought you
said there was no hoa
i would have never said that are you
sure 100
sure even a few months ago yes who do
you think
pays for everything here yeah this is
just gonna
come included i'm sorry i'm sorry yeah
okay
jack is blinded because he's just like
oh yeah i'm living in my own world
yeah yeah i'm sorry yeah laundry just
cleans itself know
we don't have a laundry machine here he
makes fun of me because i i can't do my
laundry or i don't do my lunch but i
cannot we don't have a laundry machine
here you need me to buy you one
i'll be happy too they're on back order
like we already have we ordered one it
was supposed to come
originally was supposed to come november
okay then it was like the first week of
january
then they moved it to march and now it's
like april
16th i think it's supposed to come here
april 16th right you guys order this
thing from
online that was wayfair and i purposely
got that one because it said it was in
stock
you guys have a fridge now though right
no no we have a mini fridge
okay the refrigerator was terrible so
the refrigerator i ordered
before the house actually closed so this
is like five months ago
and it was a special refrigerator to fit
the spot
this this spot to have it like be flush
with the cabinetry it was like a special
size only a few companies make it so i
didn't have a lot of choice
but kitchenaid was one of them so i
ordered from kitchenaid
and what i don't like is i ordered
through one of their like
black friday sales okay and when i did
that i locked in like a discount of a
little bit
yeah but it's so back ordered it's so
delayed even though it said also it was
in stock
oh supposed to be delivered by new
year's never did
and then it's now april yeah but if i oh
and then i called
and i said can you cancel me on this
uh and she says you know fine but then
you lose the black friday deal
dude it's not worth it we just got to
get a fridge here
yeah but then i got to order for there's
only a few companies that have that size
so that you know the stress the time
all of that it's not worth it
financially it's like that apple pencil
a discount on something just for the
inconvenience but they just they're
ruthless they don't care
did you like really like try to get into
it with them or did that i didn't
not not like aggressively but you know
firmly i stated my case
and there's nothing we could do it's i
think it's terrible
uh you know you do an exposed video you
know what i could do that like i did
with samsung i got a um
a dishwasher for rental property it
started the front
little panel yeah it started peeling
within days
and then by the time they sent someone
out sorry it's past our 30-day thing
even though i reported it days after
they sent someone so far
you know ahead in advance so when i post
on instagram
they finally were like okay we'll fix it
yeah but i got a lot of people
complaining
and thank you thank thank to thanks to
all of you guys
that when i posted on uh their instagram
i tagged them and then everyone went to
their page it's like
right this is not good what you did to
graham please help
graham and all the comments were like
that i love it and it worked
it worked so like you know i i might
have to do that with kitchenaid i don't
want to have to do that
but we might have to go to kitchenaid
and just take the mob
and just let's hammer them until i get
my refrigerator get grandma's
refrigerator that's not fair for
grandma's refrigerator we should
we should do it yeah it's it's funny
yeah it was
a situation recently where we're having
some trouble with uh the pool we have in
arizona with the finish of it
and um my dad was like yeah you should
you know put your lawyers on them and
come after them
and things like that i'm like first dad
like my lawyers don't like deal with
that type of stuff and i'm like second
like if i really wanted to hurt them i
would come out on social media about
this
like he's like well they'll fear lawyers
i'm like you know what they fear worse
is like the retaliation from like
somebody that has a lot of followers and
like
you know ruining that brand or hurting
it severely you know by
posting like you did on the samsung
thing and it's not even like you know
super malicious it's just like you but
also they listen
because also they're like oh he just put
it out there and now 80 000 people 100
000 people whatever is going to see this
oh crap we gotta we have to fix this
quick man
yeah it's cheaper for them just to fix
it yeah i was ready to make a video i
told jack
yeah he was gonna make a video he's
gonna make a video on the samsung
dishwasher a second channel but
that's a 10 minute piece explaining the
situation what's happened
showing the dialogue back and forth but
so like proving like here are the dates
that all of this happened here's what's
here's what's going on here are all the
other people who are affected by this
because i got so many other people
saying oh my god the same thing happened
to me this
like literally same thing they didn't
want to fix it so i wanted to do this uh
this piece on you've been interested
yeah i mean very out of your
norm for con you know like content right
but um
hmm it had been interesting imagine it
ranks number one for samsung on youtube
for like
two years straight like you type in
samsung anything it's like first thing
it comes up like
oh gosh all right but no i mean that's a
good thing about having a following i
mean there's a lot of good things about
having a big following behind you but
one of them is like
hey man you need somebody to listen like
they're going to listen if you post
something on social media right
so i saw in your instagram story you got
a new watch and you said
that graham has been getting you into
watches and i see it's
yeah it looks pretty nice yeah frank
muyola
so or some people say frank mueller um
yeah
thanks i appreciate it man it's a it's a
new one
um yeah graham kind of got me into it uh
many many months ago we went to the
rolex store
um and you're like oh you should get a
nice watch because i've never bought
like nice watches
and like i i rolex's aren't my style
like i don't like really like the
classical look and things like that
and uh like patex and like what uh you
know the other audamars
or whatever yeah and um so i'm not
really into those styles i i love like
um
uh there's a richer millie uh that's a
brand i really like but the watches are
like
way stupid like price hundred grand yeah
yeah
yeah like insane and so frank you know
the frank mueller they make some watches
that are pretty
interesting like uh visually like color
schemes and things like that
and um you know made in geneva and i
really like like that brand and so i've
bought a couple watches from them now
but um yeah i'm not like i wouldn't call
myself super into watches but
um i do like a watch like this like i've
thought many times like would i buy an
apple watch i'm like i'm just
i'm not that type of person um my wife
loves her apple watch she doesn't care
about any like other kinds of watches
and things like that but i think there's
just something about wearing
a traditional like watch that i just
really like like you know
so yeah i'm getting into it's a good
looking watch it fits you well
appreciate it thank you i appreciate it
man
yeah i have to have a little color and
flare it has to have like a little style
to it for
for it to represent me i feel like so
yeah should jack get a watch i've been
trying to tell him
for a long time now get the watch every
month he waits it keeps going up in
price i got a place in scottsdale
arizona man you gotta come out there
with us yeah i'll take you over there
and we'll negotiate a little bit with
them
yeah we'll haggle a little bit back and
forth get you a good deal man
five thousand dollars later we'll get
you something ten thousand what do you
wanna spend just
two thousand ten thousand it's a pretty
big switch what jack wants is i
i'm telling him submariner get a good
rolex submariner yeah
black dial so you you could wear like a
classical watch like
traditional yeah i like the way it looks
okay i think that's more of a sports
i wouldn't say technically it is a
sports watch yeah okay
so mariner is a watch that can go with
anything that's one of the watches that
it's it's respectable okay wear it with
a suit you could wear it
playing basketball because it was
initially created
for divers but why is why is that now
like the standard for like i love the
design the design
just it's classic design interesting
and you you posted something recently it
was um i don't know if there's a video i
saw our instagram story
some rolex sold for some crazy amount of
money well daytona daytona
the original rolex daytona one and a
half million dollars wow yeah
it was just recently yeah at auction oh
my gosh wouldn't have for a watch
i'm gonna watch whoa do you know who
bought it no interesting
wow was it an nft
yeah so it's sold as an nfc it's not
even a real watch it's a picture
of the it's a screenshot of the watch
could you imagine if the nft
sold for more money than the actual
watch it wouldn't be surprised
like oh my gosh yeah how much did your
watch cost
this one i got i negotiated uh down to
6 400 before taxes so this one's much
more
affordable my other one is 10 000.
that's a good looking watch too like
thanks i appreciate it it's it's like
lower end frank though
like my other ones uh like graham felt
this one and he's like oh it's pretty
light
the other one man the other one's really
like you pick it up and you're like oh
this is a watch man
but uh yeah i like this one i like this
style more than my other watch i'll be
honest the other one i bought but now
i'm going to chill on watches for a
while i want to become a watch addict
my wife bought me this thing for
christmas like one of those store your
watch things
like where you can put like water yeah
but my problem is i'm like well now i
feel like i got to fill it up and i'm
like i don't i can't just
spin anything no it's not spin it's just
like a nice thing you you know it has
like the middle
furry piece yeah sure yeah and then you
just like a glass case on top of it but
then i'm like oh man i don't want to
have a million different watches because
now this is the only watch i wear pretty
much almost every day
so that's what i found like if i buy
something i really like like i just use
that over and over and then
the old thing ahead just goes to waste
and collects dust but
yeah that's happened every single time i
got a watch so are you getting into like
a bunch of alternative investments
because you just bought
a pokemon box first let's see it oh
let's see
okay let's bust this so explain the
story behind this
why'd you buy this so what happened here
with the pokemon okay
is uh somebody in the private group they
said uh they they
showed a picture and they were like i'm
trying to sell um and they're also in
coaching they're like i'm trying to sell
i want money but i'm trying to sell um
one of my two pokemon boxes
not sure which one but one i'm asking
thirty thousand
and the other one he's asking forty
thousand and the forty thousand one
was for one that had i think it was a
blue wing charizard
so something about that you have a
higher probability of getting a shadow
list blah blah wait wait
so that was a shadowless box it could
have been uh andre i spoke to andre
about it he's like i don't think it is
um i don't know why andre said that but
he's like i don't think it is even
though it was a blue wing charizard i
don't know how andre knew
um maybe he's wrong i don't know because
i'm pretty sure you could tell
which one is going to be shadowless and
which one is not maybe
yeah and he's like like andre sounded
really confident about it so i was like
okay
and so yeah i asked you know andre text
him about it if he was interested i text
you
i don't even think you text back so i
was like okay graham doesn't care graham
clearly doesn't care and then andre was
like uh you know he wasn't really
like that into it so like he didn't tell
me like oh try to get it for this price
or something
so then i negotiate and i said you know
what about 20
uh 25 000 and yeah he went with 25 000
that's what we ended up doing and then i
gave him 500 bucks extra so he could
like get a hotel room for the night so i
wanted to deliver like asap
so yeah that's it this is this is the uh
the box here okay so just hope i don't
unravel it somehow it's crazy to think
it's crazy to think this first edition
would be worth like half a million bucks
right now yeah yeah if it was first
edition
yeah and these have been going for like
35 to like
45 i've been watching on ebay so that's
just the base set unlimited
yeah that's just a base set from i think
99.
um and so the gentleman that bought this
um he uh bought it for
he negotiated for i think it was 2 000
bucks in 2016.
and um so yeah i'm like wow that's uh
you know he made a pretty sweet profit
on that like in
you know over is money uh in a matter of
a few years so
it would be interesting if you could
invest like on an exchange
in like the pokemon market or in the
rolex market
or the ferrari market that oh man that's
an interesting concept that's probably
the next billion that's probably like
how you can nft them off right so like
you create an nft for partial shares of
or
ownership of a ferrari or something i
like that idea yeah
and if you push it down a little bit in
the middle you can see the cards and
whatnot
right but yeah i was um i i wouldn't
have bought that
if it was just some random person i'll
be right it was a trusted yeah
yeah it was like you know smaller than i
would think here looks
bigger online yeah like yeah absolutely
yeah magic jack just starts unwrapping
oh my god
hey that would make for an epic episode
man this is so cool
so what's what's your plan with that uh
just hold it
yeah i'm gonna get a nice case for a
nice clear case yeah um and just
hold it um for uh yeah long term i don't
know you know i could always resell it
but i'm like
i don't really want to i think it's just
a cool piece to have it's almost like
art
yeah i almost look at it as like an art
piece like you know i'll put it out or
you know bring it out every once in a
while and we can
we can look at it be like whoa look at
this booster box
i just yeah man i just want to open it
that's that's the thing
i want to open it and find the charizard
oh gosh it's in there
it's probably in there it's probably
like it could be two 90 it's in there
because
there was a there was a box logan opened
recently
yeah wow yeah then like two chances too
or three chances and then yeah
the other thing i could do if i really
wanted to i could actually sell pack by
pack um
you know just you'd be able to probably
say if if you did shout outs with that
you'd probably be able to sell them
about a thousand dollars a piece
yeah that makes sense yeah but yeah in
gentlemen i bought it from he's like
yeah it's gonna sell
you know keep it keep it boxed up he's
like keep it sealed up because it's
gonna be worth way more money than
why is he selling so he just when he
needed some money he wanted some money
so
uh buy some stocks and stuff like that
so yeah i'm like
uh he wants to get in the six-figure
club and he's not he's not there yet so
he's like
you know that twenty five thousand he
could put in the market and what not so
what about the other box
the one with the other box i didn't buy
that was the one i was going after
actually uh and i offered him 35 000
but that had a tear in the plastic now
he believes it should be worth still
just as much even with that tear
but i didn't want to buy something that
had a tear in it i wanted the
you know you saw that that looked
perfect and so i'm like i really
even though the other one was a blue
wing charizard after andre told me he's
like
that's not more than likely shadowless i
was like with the tear i was like ah
forget it
why so it had a tear in it how big was
the tear pretty big
it was like um like a good chunk like
this much off of it
so um yeah he said he did that like
shortly after he had bought the box like
showing it off to somebody and uh so i
was like
oh no you know what i would have done
you you buy it for a reasonable price
let's say 27. he wouldn't have sold for
27. really yeah
no i got him down 35 and that's like
what we had agreed on but then it was
like
um the tear and i was like no and then
you know this one
and i was like i could spend less money
and i felt like he kind of
really wanted to keep that one because
of the whole blue wing charizard thing
um i feel like he liked that one even
more than than this one
so you bought it for 35 and then sold
off all the packs and kept a few for
yourself
but then it's shipping and dealing with
that but yeah
and then i wouldn't have been able to
buy this one because he was only selling
one oh
yeah he wants to keep one he wants to
kind of like hedge his bet like well
pokemon's hot right now
let me cash out of one of them and uh
keep the other one long-term he wouldn't
have sold both of them
yeah i might have tried to pursue it if
he was selling both but he
he was not going to do that he was like
it's it's you whatever one you want to
go for i'm keeping that the one
wow you would have bought both if you
give you the opportunity maybe
yeah i would have considered it but that
wasn't even an option for him it's like
it's it's one of the other essentially
so
yeah so anyways i'll hold it long term
we'll see what happens with it
and um no matter what it is it is like
at the end of the day like
these are becoming more and more extinct
uh the first editions are almost
non-existent now right
um you know whoever is holding those
it's very few and far between
because a lot of people have i think
yeah how many does gary have gary has
like there's nine
nine of them all right and he probably
has one of the bigger collections of
anybody i would imagine the most
it is the biggest oh yeah it's confirmed
yeah and that's the first editions first
edition
nine nine first edition they're probably
worth about half a million a piece
yeah yeah and so wow yeah the few people
that have some
first editions aren't going to likely
open them they're just going to hold
them they're not going to flood the
market with them there's probably a
limited amount
and these i feel like are becoming
really extinct now like which aren't
first edition
so yeah i looked at it and i was like
and you know he was pretty confident
that over time it's gonna be worth 100k
but obviously you know it's just
it's dependent upon what another person
is willing to pay over time
so but did you see this as an investment
or did you see it as just something to
spend your money jeremy is so flushed
with cash right now that he's just
trying to like
get rid of it i saw graham spend 300 000
on a gt and i was like okay
well i could spend 25 000 on cars
that's even cooler can't let him out
flex me
no i did look at it as an investment but
a cool thing
yeah i will be honest like because it's
like how many opportunities do you get
for that man
and like i said i was looking at it on
ebay and for all those
you're going 35 45 50 000 and i would
have trust issues with those yeah
right i really would um so yeah i'm like
you know i'm looking at it and i'm like
you know he did well
i did well everybody's happy so we'll
see
what do you think about nfts oh i don't
have an opinion on it man
not non-fungible tokens yeah no i have
no opinion
nfts i that's really i know that's like
the hot subject right now but that's
just not one
you know every time they talk about on
millennial money i'm just quiet yeah we
just see your face
[Laughter]
looking at the camera directly i'm like
no but uh yeah i honestly have no
opinion
it's interesting uh something i'll keep
an eye on and uh i don't really have any
anything to add their value you should
come out with your own nft
yeah that'd be a holy smoke is to say no
jokers you gotta be flipping my
flapjacks having me like it's an artwork
where i'm like flipping a flapjack or
something
i would love to do an edit i think it
would be cool every thumbnail
i do turn that into a one of one nft
wow i think that would be kind of cool i
think that's a great idea
signed i don't know if we could sign nfc
like have that be like the original
it's gonna be 1280 by 720 or you know
it's it's not gonna be a
super high quality thing but just every
thumbnail is its own enough
your thumbnails are just so dang good
you know i just trying
i mean you know i was talking to chris
about this recently because you know
he's going to do that that clips channel
and whatnot
and we were talking and i was like you
know trying to explain to him like
how much of an art it is to title a
video great
and you are you are the top level and
everybody falls underneath you and i
feel like i've gotten to a pretty good
level but you're on another level like
and um
like people don't really realize like
how much it's a skill
yeah like you know i i know you won't
gas yourself up but it's a skill like
thumbnails
titles it's a true skill and i'm sure
you have experienced this jack being
around graham every day for you know i
don't know the last two years or
whatever
it's a true skill um to really title
something
an interesting title that makes people
say i've got to watch this video i've
got to check this out man
and yeah so your thumbnails man you
maybe have something there you should do
your titles
it's it's honestly it's lately become my
least favorite part
right yeah why because of how much
pressure there is
to do well on a title like you could
have the best video in the world
but without the proper title and
thumbnail it's all for nothing
that's true that's a really good so i
hate having to be like
what title is gonna work what thumbnail
is gonna work how do we make this stand
out
there becomes a point where it's just
it's so much riding on this
that it's like any mistake in that like
even i go with jack and we'll like come
back and like
should we do this green or do you like
this bluish color instead on this right
like every little detail has to be so
precise and if it's not
the video's done yeah and so then and
then there's like thousands of dollars
on the line
per title and thumbnail that can make a
huge difference throughout the channels
yeah it's true
and uh then it's like the algorithm oh
no i hit that i hit that again
yeah so i mean it could be it could
honestly be a hundred thousand dollar
mistake
to have like three titles and thumbnails
not perform yeah 100 so you know and
it's just like so
so i don't like the pressure of it the
pressure there's no pressure it's just
having fun
yeah by all means um and it's
it's good though when it does hit when
it does hit it's like we did something
right
yeah and sometimes you know i'm sure
there's times where you think something
is
great and then you're like oh that then
just didn't hit
it's almost like a i feel like it's
almost like being a musician right
you're a musician
and you you come out with this song and
you're like oh man this is a banger man
this is gonna go huge and then it like
just doesn't hit and you're like
what went wrong there do you ever have
that yeah all the time okay
and when it doesn't hit i'm like oh
that's why
sometimes you sometimes it'll post you
think it'll do well it doesn't and then
you look at it again and be like
yeah no i could see why it didn't do
well let's change it up
so do you envy kevin at all from the
respect of like
he puts out so much content that it
almost doesn't matter
i mean his titles and thumbnails are
still somewhat important but he puts out
such a
a gauntlet of content all the time he's
almost removed that stress of like
yeah i don't know some not really
because
i know i couldn't do what kevin does so
i don't look at that so much with envy
like oh look at kevin doing this
i mentioned to jack it's like kevin
could get away with these titles and
thumbnails and get so many views but i
just
i know i can't make five videos a day
yeah i can't livestream as much as he
does so it's like
i i don't i don't envy or i don't look
at that with jealousy because i know
like
he's on a different level than i am in
terms of what he's doing it's completely
separate
from mine so no that makes sense but
yeah it is nice from the perspective of
not having that stress of uh
every video has got to happen i think
kevin could probably
all he needs to do in my opinion is just
go live twice a day
once market open once market close
if he just and then one summary that's
enough context
that's more than you can't even watch
all of the content he's doing no
you can't do it you literally even at
two two at speeds
he has to um you know
keep it up i think if he starts feeding
only let's say two videos hypothetically
a day
and you go from six videos to two videos
like
views are gonna go down there's no doubt
in my mind views will go down
and um and then you get into this whole
bad cycle around the algorithm and then
like starts feeding you less and then
you kind of get it you know
i don't know i feel like that could be
that's you know
yeah i don't know man i don't see that
working uh i mean i've tried it with
financial education three where i went
content crazy
got view pushed views way up and then
dropped off content and then try to go
to
up again and it wouldn't be the same and
so the great thing with him is he
continued to pour out more content where
he also started doing two a day then
three a day
then four day and now he's doing like
six videos a day but if you start going
backwards man
it would be like you going to one video
a week
you know or shoot no that would be like
you going one video a month
you know because he's putting out six a
day right it'd be like you doing one a
month gosh
yeah now that would just be uh uh you'd
be devastating your channel i would
assume you know cause even if you got
a million people to watch that one video
come out with each month it's just
there's no way you're feeding the other
videos right
so jeremy everyone wants to know how is
your net worth divided up
oh divide it up okay so
ah it's complicated subject because i
mean sometimes
you know it's interesting like do you
value youtube channels
i'd say let's just talk about hard cash
cash we're not taking anything out do
you do i value my business or
no no so this is just like straight up
money you could pull out okay
so i am
oh gosh heavy stocks 60
plus stocks um
maybe 15 20 real estate
rest cash
yeah or maybe 25 cash
no let me see so cash i'm probably
i probably actually have more cash than
i do real estate so
yeah uh i'd probably say
twenty percent cash ten percent real
estate seventy percent stocks
um and and and uh point zero zero zero
zero one percent uh pokemon cards now
you know my network
just kidding so yeah definitely
definitely stock heavy
still to this day and and i don't see
that probably ever changing so
what are you doing with that cash so
most of it i just keep unfortunately i'm
like checking account savers accounts
things like that um
some of it i have been putting into um a
little bit into kryptos i forgot i'm a
teeny bit in the cryptos now
little usdc uh you did that are you
getting
interest yeah like nine percent or
whatever how much how much cash did you
put in there
not much only probably maybe 30 000 to
start
because i'm a little unsure i'm like oh
maybe 20 000 20 or 30.
okay i'm a little unsure because i'm
like i just i'm still having trouble
wrapping my head around that i'm just
like
how can somebody pay this nine percent
interest rate and still make money
that's right that's crazy to me man
unless they're printing their own usdc
so there's like no one can give a direct
answer to that question
yeah everyone's like well they lend it
out on the blockchain and then they
return it back to you and they make some
money on it and they
but like i can't put a lot in it because
i'm still a little sketchy the same
and like they say if it's too good but
too good to be true for me it's too good
to be true i mean if they offered
three percent i'd actually feel more
comfortable yeah because then i'm like
all right i can wrap my mind around that
not nine
mm-hmm yeah so you know cause who's to
say they can't just print
more usdc to pay you back
mm-hmm who's who are buying these loans
at like what thirty percent then how are
they able to give nine percent
who are these people i don't know
anybody that's receiving loans from yeah
it's like funds and whatnot for the most
part it's like uh different
uh crypto funds and things like that
that supposedly they're making so much
uh money that it makes sense for them to
basically
um had that cash go in their account
andre could probably explain 10 times
better we should we should
have tried yeah yeah i feel like we
should really like push andre on this
millennial money one day i think it
would be interesting because
you know he's really the of us he's by
far the most crypto guy so i would love
it if he could really like
dive into that andre if you see this
which you probably won't man we're going
to push you on this andre if you're
watching this comment
i'm watching i'm watching three four one
two three four five
exclamation point asterisk
yeah i know nobody's ever everyone's
tried explaining it to me i don't
understand it yeah and i'm not good at
explaining either like i
kind of get the concept but i still i'm
like how do they make money on this this
sounds like insane but anyway so a
little bit of money over there but yeah
i'm just i'm still stocks heavy man i
don't know if i ever see a day where i'm
not stocks heavy
um to be honest you know because even in
a market where i feel like we're a
little richly valued no doubt
i still find deals so do you own any
like funds
or anything nope zero zero funds zero
etfs zero funds
uh yep what about a business you're
starting
what oh gosh we're gonna start with that
one
yeah so we got a business we're starting
i'm joking
we got a business we're starting but um
i can't talk a ton about
it but it's been it's been a lot set up
you know obviously you're one of the
biggest
you know shareholders in the company and
then got a lot of other
talented people in on that project
really looking forward to that it is app
related i don't want to get into the
details of it because i'll let that
speak when
you know we can really speak about the
details which we're not that level yet
but
yeah i mean that that's really exciting
man it's exciting to put
together a new company that's fresh um
but man it's a lot it's a lot you know
it definitely takes a lot of my time
it uh you know dealing with you know the
setting up of the company with lawyers
because we're doing it like real like
this is like real proper like like
delaware corporation
um dealing with all the different
stakeholders and and you know the
the team behind it that's creating it
and whatnot man
it's definitely taken a good amount of
my time but it's uh it's going to be
exciting when we launch it i think it's
going to be fun to do something
uh that's so far out there that
um you know it's trying to try to do
something really really big
and i think that's that's fun and so
yeah we'll have more to share with you
guys in the comments what if there's a
link down below in the description where
we could uh have people sign up for an
announcement can we do that
we can do that we can do that maybe even
ping comment no promises but uh yeah
certainly we could do something in the
description where you know at least
folks can maybe uh get on the wait list
to maybe
maybe they'll be beta beta folks that
that can you know test it before
we really get it into the market yeah
yeah when's the launch date launch date
oh my gosh
that's the hardest part i i would say
between the next
30 in 90 days like i think worst case
scenario 90 days i think best case
scenario 30 days so
somewhere in there we should launch i'm
hoping
within the next 30 days at least to have
a decent product in our hands that we
can start testing
and playing around with and seeing like
the bugs and those sorts of things and
maybe get to the early beta crew
and maybe these folks may be watching
this video can be in that that earliest
stage to get their hands on it
and try it out and see things like that
so but yeah it's really tough i mean
it's not you know when you're creating
something like this it's not really like
you just say well it's done like in 14
days from now
it doesn't really work like that so um
but yeah i'm thinking 30-90 days so
let's hope
let's hope i did make an announcement of
it in
one of my videos on wednesday coming up
i'll maybe have you
listened to that i just i just said it's
a financial app
that covers uh information that i'm not
able to discuss on the channel oh that's
perfect so
vague enough yeah exactly but uh yeah it
extends beyond what i could do in a
video
oh that's exciting yeah that's great all
right yeah i'm looking super forward to
it man
it it's something like um i've been
wanting to build something
um that's a big uh maybe in the finance
community um
that you know a lot of people really
enjoy get a ton of value out of that's a
thing it is a free product
that's where i think is really
interesting so yeah we'll we'll see
it it's a lot of work man it's a lot of
work to really put it together and
things like that so
but uh yeah i'm happy and jack you'll be
the first to try it out okay
i'm kind of excited as long as you keep
my pokemon card safe okay
but yeah man i'm i'm pumped so cool
probably talk about do you have any hot
takes hot takes
yeah uh any drama any gossip any drama
anything what's going on with you and
kevin right oh
my gosh because he was he called me out
the other day he's talking talking some
crap
yeah yeah yeah he was mad i heard it
yeah i heard him yelling from the other
room no way over the phone he was
talking about your family and like
yeah no you're alive
no i'm joking you took it seriously like
oh my gosh yeah you know i don't like it
if somebody talks bad about my stock
so yeah i mean you know with with the
whole kevin situation you know
i i kind of just got fed up recently
with um people
like being like oh kevin said this about
your stock or
you know whatever stock and um it just
kind of like like
frustrates me because i'm like then i
have to answer questions and like
i feel like oh i have to go out there
and like prove my case against why
kevin's wrong or something like that to
these these individuals and so that gets
a little frustrating
and i have tremendous amount of respect
for kevin
as a youtuber and just as like a person
like tremendous amount of respect where
i
don't have respect for kevin is as a
stock picker yet
it doesn't mean i can't get there over
time it's just like when you're in the
stock market community you've got to
like
have stock after stock hit and you know
like like
you know big winners that aren't just
like the ones that you know you're
hearing from other people essentially
and so you know with kevin i'm like why
do i even have to answer questions in
regards to
kevin's opinion on tattooed chef or
dropbox i heard something he had said
oh about dropbox and so i'm like that's
what really led to this frustration and
that that's why i was like
let me let me make this public let me
let me let me make this case
publicly and um go that route
and now we got what is that a phone what
is that i don't know what's going on
is that yours that's mine yeah it's your
phone i bet it's my mom
it's probably you want to get up and see
his car just tell me who's calling me
well imagine it's kevin
yeah could you imagine but anyways yeah
anyway
so yeah so that's that was the situation
there i think the beef's over now to be
honest i think it's played out um
you know i've stayed in my bowl case he
doesn't really have a bear case but he's
not
uh you know super positive on it so
so beneath all of the fun and games
there was a little bit of
you did feel like uh yeah disrespected
that you had to respond to someone
exactly maybe that hadn't quite proved
themselves in your point of view yeah
community yeah because i i looked at
kevin and i said you know like i said i
respect him a ton
as a person i respect him as a ton as a
youtuber i'm like as a beast
but yeah when you're coming to my arena
which is stock picking
stock market investing i say okay like
like what have you proven like why
should i have to
you know like go against you or
something like that like like
you know why should i have to answer
questions on this person's behalf and
prove like
my stock against yours because like
kevin like i respect him also as a real
estate investor like i remember i bought
his real estate course before it was
even like formed
and so you know when all son you know
but now he's like so into stocks right
and he's really got into in last year
he's posting a lot of stock market
videos and things like that and then
yeah i just like i just got frustrated
with it and i'm like okay you know i'm
gonna
i'm gonna talk about these things so but
that goes for anybody
in the stock market community like
sometimes you know folks pop up here and
there
and you're like you know who's this
person and things like that and it's
just
you know yeah it's something you'd have
to deal with um
in the communities so so what do you say
to an individual
no one is specific that may not own any
tattooed chef
uh i won't say anything to him to be
honest buy the product it's out at your
local target
okay that's about it but uh as far as
the stock i like the stock
if he likes the stock i like this if
he's in
i'm in oh god he's still in i'm still in
yeah so anyways we'll see how that one
plays out that's a 5-10 year play out
that i think has massive
massive upside potential we shall see it
would be interesting to look at kevin's
returns
this last year and like analyze it per
stock and see
what it's what it's come out to be yeah
yeah i i'm sure kevin's doing really
good
um and so there's no question about that
it's just like you have to prove
yourself over a period of time that's
that
yeah you know what i mean like i've seen
it before with you know like there would
be somebody in the private group that
gets like a 500
return yeah like blows me out of the
water and it doesn't mean they're
necessarily a better investor than me
they destroyed me last year but like
it's like what can you prove
it's like youtube right let's say
youtube's a game like somebody could
come out
in the finance space and come out with
some viral video gets like a million
views
doesn't mean they're better than you or
it doesn't mean like oh they're the king
of youtube now because they had that
video that got
10 million views or something like that
um so
yeah i mean that's that's just the way
it is in every single space and uh yeah
stock market investing is competitive
man and i'm really competitive when it
comes to that
and i take my my craft pretty serious
and uh
you know anybody that kind of comes in
and i'm just like you know i'm not sure
how serious they are
it i get a little uh in my feelings
about it so that's good you're
passionate about it oh
i respect that yeah yeah really so but
yeah what's one thing in investing uh
specifically stocks let's say that you
think you could do better in
oh when it comes to stocks um i mean i'm
always trying to get better at
everything
you know it's not like there's one
glaring thing nowadays it's just like
you know that holds saying like one
percent better i don't even know if i
can get one percent better but
i can always like understand more
business models i think that's the one
thing like understand business models
maybe understand them faster
because sometimes it takes weeks or
months for me to like really get wrap my
head around it
so that that's maybe one thing but yeah
i i i play
you know grow stocks value stocks i'm in
dividend stocks
i'm in turnaround plays so i'm kind of
almost you know doing everything now as
far as an investor
um but it's always about doing it even
better so
what's thing one thing you think you
could be doing better graham as a
youtuber
as a youtuber yeah uh probably taking
more risk and
and off topic content that's probably
what i could do so like diversifying the
content
right i like that that's probably what i
could do the vlog
channel and then what do you think
jeremy could oh yeah
i think jeremy can improve your
thumbnails yeah i think your thumbnails
are uh
you the the main picture of you is
blurry really
it's really it's really bad high-res
thumbnails yeah that's what's crazy
because i thought it was really good now
this is what's up and i don't like the
hat
okay i don't like that yeah you use the
hat in every thumbnail so i would do
a um a less exaggerated face actually
funny enough
okay less over the top um the high
quality
wow okay no that's great to know i'm
just going to go on a photo shoot with
some somebody that has a great camera
yeah because it's funny because i look
at it i'm like oh that's really high
quality but
like i said there's levels to things man
and like you feel like it's not that
high
i think the videos themselves are fine
because i listen to them so to me it it
it's
it's memorable to see the the goofy
little pictures
coming up so i don't really look at the
video itself yeah but the title
thumbnail or something that are
important
titles are okay it's the thumbnail that
i feel like you could really improve on
the thumbnail wow that's good to know
yeah
i mean you know i created that thumbnail
uh from millennial money and then you
created one and i was just like oh my
gosh that blew me out of the water i'm
like you're the thumbnail man
yeah no money now i'm like that you got
to be abstract now
like abstract in terms of the thumbnail
like it's really got to be it's got to
make people question like
what am i looking at sometimes it
doesn't even need to make sense
no honestly so long as it gets people's
attention for example we'll make a video
about a real estate crash but we'll be
happy to put the background
as a galaxy or as like a huge like
like war zone just because it gets
nuclear
yeah it doesn't necessarily need to make
sense with the content
yeah but you see it and the colors are
so vibrant you're like whoa and it stops
you for one second
just enough for you to see oh let me see
the title or just enough for you to
think
should i watch this it gets your
attention yeah that's interesting yeah
there's one i made that makes no sense
whatsoever but it did really well
it's um the stock market is about to
drop
again okay and the thumbnail was
me in a middle of a stock chart
and the one side is up high the other
side is down
this is a random stock chart that we
just happened to find okay
just i don't even know if it was like
for the right decade but we did an
arrow to one side and then a circle on
the other with the question mark
yeah making people think like no idea
we're here and
what's going on over there made no sense
there was
nothing behind it but it just looked
cool yeah like stuff like that
or um in our thumbnail we were talking
about a split so i like took the images
and like split them in half
like one per one side versus another so
like yeah just it doesn't need to make
sense the other one is like
the end of the stock market something
like that where i'm like half underwater
that was so good i loved it thank you
that was my favorite thumbnail that was
the thumbnail that we did
that was 10 to 10. thanks that title
because that title made me say
oh what like like what does that mean
like you know you almost feel like you
got to watch it it like uh andre had a
really good one recently with ethereum
ethereum is about to self-destruct i
loved it i was like oh gosh man
like how can you not watch that what
does that mean yeah exactly
we've been coming out with different
terms now that make no sense it's like
the stock market just flipped totally
just
reversed the interest money collected
three years yeah and so what we do is
we're looking up synonyms of certain
words
and then be like this sounds kind of
cool that sounds neat
yeah so graham was thinking about using
the word tantrum in a title
it didn't really make sense in the
context because you when you think of it
i'm using that when the stock market
just threw a tantrum yeah because it's
like you think of a little kid throwing
a tantrum but
it would get your attention and that's
all that really matters oh man that's
good stuff
you know i was thinking about this one
night i was like
imagine like i wonder if there's ever
going to be like a next generation of
finance youtubers that are like
way bigger than like us and like
like could you picture that or could is
it like maybe not
youtube but maybe another social media i
would say another social media probably
tick tock
okay where it's just like we're we're
like blown away like wow that many
people watch
those videos and stuff i think so at
some point yeah just like dave ramsey
right yeah it's like back in the time
like back in the day like still the
biggest though
well maybe not one of you different
maybe a different demographic yeah as
well
but yeah like he owned his own platform
i guess yeah yeah there's gotta be
a bit ten years i don't know yeah at
some point it could be interesting yeah
because i mean our our
our generation we weren't really the
ones that grew up on youtube like we
started using youtube but it will be
interesting with like the kids that are
on the come up right now that
maybe grew up with youtube like since
they were kids
and then they get like financial
knowledge and then they share it and
maybe they understand like the youtube
stuff
better than we do and then yeah we look
back and it'd be interesting you know
what it's gonna be it's it's i have a
feeling it's gonna be another platform i
don't think it's gonna be youtube i
think it's gonna be some
like a tick tock where they're all
sophisticated maybe it's like you put on
these vr like this headset like
everything's all crap like we would try
this and just not get it
yeah they'll understand it so i have a
feeling it's gonna be something
it's gonna be something like that no i
could picture that yeah
that should be it and one day we're
going to be too old we're going to be
unrelatable
to like the new the new demographic the
new audience they're going to see like
oh look at the grandpas
they're talking about to buy and hold
now we're going to be trading some like
futuristic
call option hedged alpha beta
theta gang whatever it is there's going
to be some new
level of investing that we don't even
know exists so what's interesting is you
know i always flirt around with this
idea of leaving youtube or like like
leaving social media but if i want to
stay on the great news is like
um as you get older you actually get a
lot more respect you know
in the stock market like the more
decades you get in and you do on a high
level
like the more people are going to want
to watch you and stay tuned
and stay around um because at the end of
the day like you know what i learned is
like if you
if people make money from you if they
really like hearing your opinion they're
going to stay around
i've just tested like you know i i mean
i could i put in probably the most
minimal work to videos but people still
watch it because they really just
they're they're not there to be
entertained they literally just want to
hear my opinion on
what next stock i'm buying or what i'm
doing in the market like you're not
there for
some flashy you know show like you know
respect to you and like andre like
you know i could see people watching
your channel andre's channel who
you know they they are you know they
want a show like you guys put on a show
man it's it's flip it's amazing and it's
like you know my videos it's not like
that it's like you're just there
to hear the opinion man and that's it
and so with the stock market community
like
you know the longer you're in it and
proving yourself like the more respect
you get so that's the
no i'm like a young i'm still like a
really young person in the stock market
like
only being 12 or 13 years but being 31
like most people that have a lot of
respect in the stock market are 50s
60s at least 40s usually 40s 50s 60s
warren buffett 90 you know what i mean
it's like
so that's a cool thing as far as that
goes but
yeah man do you have any advice for
graham
on his stock picking or investing
strategies
uh graham i mean i feel like he could be
maybe more aggressive
you know graham you you're you know
you're you're very play safe
i would say um so maybe a little more
aggressive
um but that's about it i mean you do
pretty good
you know um i i don't feel like you're
trying to be
like a professional stock picker i feel
like you're just like you look at
something you're like yeah that looks
like a pretty good deal let me
buy some of that i don't think you're
the type person that's like listening to
conference calls and stuff like that
yeah so you know and you mostly just
i literally watch what kevin does and
buy
his stocks i'm kidding
so i sold out a tattoo chef shorted
walgreens
shorter planet of 13. yeah no that was
that was too far great
put it all in shift oh shift what is
going on with that company
let's look into that one okay oh dang
well anyways you're mostly index funds
you you you
dollar cash i know i actually i'm more
now an individual stuff because just
because
those went up so much okay um i don't
know i'm like
30 40 index funds and then 60 individual
stocks
okay started off 50 50 but those
individual stock really
took off so interesting maybe it's like
35 percent uh
it is there uh here's an interesting ad
break
uh is there have you even thought about
the chance of
ever leaving youtube in like a time
frame or is it so far away that you like
can't even imagine yourself
i think about it every now and then okay
um and it's like well you know if
if i stop do you kind of go out on the
top or do you keep keep going
so i think it's sump at some point it's
it's probably got a shift to something
more sustainable it's just
it's the main channel takes such a long
time to plan out every video
so at some point it might go more to
like the second channel the
the podcast maybe a vlog okay
i don't know you know by the time this
posts we're actually going to have the
first episode of this to family
oh yeah yeah we started this to family
yeah so that's a vlog
um yeah so the goal is that
we could post one to two episodes a week
as a bonus
and basically like i am telling jack i
don't want to go out of my way
i don't want to do anything special i
don't want anything scripted nothing
crazy
just i feel like throughout the week
we'll have 10 minutes of content
behind the scenes just behind the scenes
stuff just yeah it doesn't have to even
be work related just
random stuff 10 minutes of content for
an entire week that's entertaining to
watch
that's the goal and just post once a
week yeah i like that
maybe twice if there's something
exciting going on yeah yeah no i can see
that that's pretty
cool but i think yeah at some point
something more sustainable
because i really like i can't be making
three videos a week in the main channel
indefinitely
yeah it's it's it's taken its toll yeah
and some days i love it and like that's
all i want to do and other days it's
like
i just i gotta get a video out because i
don't want to fall behind i don't want
to not post a video
so it's a fine balance between the two
yeah it's it's performance on a high
level man i don't think that's the thing
people
get about it it's it's like i remember
when the paul brothers were going crazy
you know jake and logan like they were
pulling in
you know 3 million at least a video for
jake and it was like 5 million 6 million
for logan
and i remember watching them and i just
like man if they keep going on this
they're going to be some of the biggest
celebrities in the world and uh
eventually you know the whole
you know four situation happened with
logan and then jake kind of stopped but
it was just like it was
it's clear like eventually like it was
gonna be too much like
especially that vlog lifestyle i'm
trying to make a vlog every day i
remember casey neistat when casey
neistat was going crazy on youtube and
he was pulling in like
at that time he was the biggest before
jake and logan took
the mantle and uh but he just always
used to talk about like
how it was so taxing it was like every
day seven days a week constantly
thinking about it constantly
and he's like you know it almost caused
him to get a divorce and stuff like that
because
just too much and uh yeah i mean you
know you want to stay on top it's it's
fun but man it is
it is uh yeah it's taxing it's stressful
i want to keep it going as long as i can
but i realize
at some point it's got a skill back yeah
so
it's probably not going to be just all
of a sudden nothing it'll probably be
well now
now it's twice a week or no it might be
once a week or something it's a little
bit more
relaxed yeah i could see it now
yeah i mean it'll be interesting you
know with you to like let somebody else
kind of like let's say take the mantle
uh from you like over time you know
whoever that person is like you know
and and kind of letting go of like i
feel like you're kind of still the king
of
of youtube finance even though kevin
gets more views than by far
everybody right but he puts out so much
content like i feel like still you're
kind of that guy
and it'll be interesting like if you
want to let that go
um or if that even means anything to you
or anything like that because
you are recognized as that person and
it's like somebody else takes it does it
hurt at all
sometimes you don't know until it
happens sometimes i feel like it's
better on your own terms
yeah because then it's like then you
made the choice
um and it's not done like you just you
burn out or something happens like that
so
i mean we'll we'll see the plan i mean i
at least see throughout the next
like year or two yeah keep the same
schedule or as long as they can
you're gonna wait till i retire and and
like have my head straight and then
you'll be like okay i can do it now and
then two weeks later
but regardless i think the podcast is
something absolutely keep that up the
second channel
absolutely keep that up the vlog the
vlog might actually get more interesting
if i'm not graham likes the podcast in
the second channel because
he like hands off all of this stuff
all you have to do for the podcast is
show up and obviously organize the
guests and stuff like that right
which is pretty nice yeah and like i was
thinking i was like even if
let's say i walked away from youtube i
would still want to do millennial money
every week because i'm like that's just
fun
i mean like that's a good time right get
on there still be active on social media
and like debate some stuff
the hardest part is really coming up
with a topic planning
filming editing for the main channel
title summit
you can delegate a lot of that work i
can't delegate planning
i could delegate some ideas but jack and
i spitball ideas all the time and like
we'll come up with 10 ideas but they'll
suck
so and then we're back to the drawing
board yeah uh filming i don't mind it
because i know i could get it done
mm-hmm planning is that is a tough
getting in the zone and planning out a
video that i think
would do well okay yeah oh i could see
that it's
oh it's a lot of work man anything else
jeremy
i got nothing i got one quick question
what are your top three stocks right now
top three stocks i'm buying
right now corsair gaming tattooed chef
and third would be oh man third one's
really tough between gg ttf
and facebook for number three
let's say you could only hold three
stocks for the next 10 years what stocks
oh man that's a whole different debate
there three stocks for the next 10 years
okay then i'm going
with the planet um i'm going with
tattooed chef
and i'm going with facebook no tesla
uh tesla is very compelling man
it's between tests and facebook because
it's like facebook's way safer than
tesla
um you know it's just like they're
already a cash flow machine tesla has to
become a casual machine
um but yeah maybe maybe tesla i don't
know maybe i'd kick that out
but planet's already taken risk and so
it's like do i want a planet risk
with a tesla risk with um
you know tattoo chef still is somewhat
of a risk right because i mean even
though it's a food business it's like
hyper growth
marketing yeah oh gosh
unproven marketing uh it's tough man is
picking your favorite stocks like you
know to only own
you know three stocks it's like picking
which one of your kids is your favorite
man
which one is your favorite if you have
to pick one
they see this video and like yeah it's
like remember what you said then
i'm the favorite yeah now i have the
throne
what stock do you think is really
undervalued right now
oh well i mean i just said it like i
feel like uh i feel like corsair if
we're talking just undervalued corsair
or sarah gaming crsr that's uh just
speaks undervalued it's like 4p of 20
with you know massive growth the next
five 10 years
so i feel like tattoo chef's a good
value but it's it's high growth
with you know you could say high
valuation at the moment but yeah corsair
is like yeah
it's it's hard it's like it's almost
impossible for me to look and be like oh
i didn't make any money and
on corsair over the next five years
dropbox would be up there too
but it's it's climbed a bit so yeah so
yeah
cool thank you so much for coming on
jeremy it was great seeing you as per
usual
absolutely thank you guys thanks for
having me again man i can't wait to do
this again next time it's always a good
time we talk about a lot of stuff so i
appreciate it
these are always the longest episodes
too yeah
well i mean if we could just keep
talking about stock after stock the
market it's like you know we could go
for days but yeah i appreciate it guys
thanks cool
so with that said you guys thank you so
much for watching i really appreciate it
as always make sure to subscribe
smash the like button hit the
notification bell all of our information
is down below in the description
where you can also get a free stock get
your free stock down there too it's
totally free cost you absolutely nothing
so you may as well do it
thank you guys so much and uh until next
time
because one of these is broken i wanna
make sure we're using the right ones cap
right
well